salut toi et toi alors je m'amuse comme
une fange et inutile la loyola si c'est
utile la notion qu'on cherche un artisan
jardinier qui s'occuperait de nos
buisson jeu pareil à prendre soin de ses
buissons vous devez avoir envie de vous
illustrer l'aspect c'est plus cochon
prévu si vite tomber dans le graveleux
pardon non papa et maman ont vendu la
maison de notre enfance tout ce que nous
attendons de vous c'est que vous
déblayer votre champ en mer
c'est dommage que j'aie jamais eue la
nuit des clac
ici on ne peut pas faire une fête ça
fait deux ans de liberté tu vas pouvoir
te défiler toute ma vie n'essaie pas de
manipuler on a du pain sur la planche si
tu doit inviter le beau gosse du bout de
la rue
salut je suis mort à moi c'est james
était juste un petit bonjour voila c'est
fait
c'est sûr que ça déborde un peu mais je
crois que je peux me permettre de laver
mise à l'envers
je comprends rien à ce truc j'ai
forcément melons qui sort du panier mais
j'aime bien le plus qu'apporte les
franges j'ai réfléchi
pourquoi tu ne jouera pas ce soir pour
que je puisse me lâcher comme une folle
avec grand plaisir
j'ai su que vous prépariez une fête par
une personne qui a été invité c'est
assez triste s'en rejettent comme saturé
chantilly ouais bravo pour ton titre de
championne de lutte conte disent adieu à
cette maison qui sied bien me clôture
suis le type de caïds auquel je ne suis
pas différente
mon code d'alerté encore
que chacun une étoile endroit
tant que c'est pas trop de points de vue
c'est ma boîte à musique avec mes
danseuses cette mélodie magnifique et
c'est fini